[Musique]
ma
vous venez d'où alignant dans le
vaucluse et et c'est quoi la ville la
ville avignon fameux avignon tués
je sais que moi
[Musique]
un spécial c'est vous qui le dites au
domaine national de chambord
on va donner comme d'habitude la parole
aux visiteurs la parole aux touristes
mais d'abord et bien deux trois choses
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit
on va donner cette tablette à monsieur
jean d'haussonville directeur du domaine
national de chambord
bonjour merci de nous accueillir chez
vous trois quatre questions à vous de
jouer
fréquentation en 2016 -7% 2016 à cause
des inondations et des attentats on
était à 7 135 mille visiteurs dans le
château 1 quasiment neuf cent mille en
prenant les visiteurs contre est parlée
barclays vélo le spectacle équestre
l'histoire du chat tour de mots
construction aucun 119 ça dure tout le
règne de françois 1er jusqu'au 15 147
on pense que c'est léonard de vinci qui
est le concepteur de la partie centrale
c'est un château unique au monde il a
plus de cinq siècles et il n'a quasiment
pas changé depuis le début
[Musique]
devenez beau c'est la première fois que
vous des coureurs en bas je viens de
l'équateur et
c'est pas la première fois que je suis
venu à chambord c'est la première fois
que j'étais très petit
si une des châteaux prix de beauval et
qui est très beau c'est un château pour
la chasse je crois je crois c'est bon ce
qui me pose histoire il est derrière moi
donc j'ai un peu partout
[Musique]
on a visité hier le château de blois et
le château du clos lucé et aujourd'hui
nous découvrons tous ensemble avec les
élèves le château de chambord mais dans
ma vie je n'ai jamais visité le château
de chambre qu'à vous inspire ce domaine
la mort oui je sais pas pourquoi mais ça
m'inspire la main bah franchement moi
j'aime bien je trouve ça beau je trouve
ça architectural et bien je trouve ça
détaillé et bien ce domaine en fait
c'est l'âge d'or de la renaissance
française avec françois 1er qui a voulu
affirmer son pouvoir royal et son
prestige royal à l'échelle nationale
mais aussi à l'échelle européenne
car d'ailleurs il a invité l'empereur du
saint-empire romain germanique charles
quinte pour lui montrer notre belle
architecture française et il en sait des
choses c'est ça le truc
c'est le roi célèbre achevé le projet de
françois 1er
mallet 14 bien louis xiv à prolonger le
rêve de françois 1er
il est le consolidateur de chambord on
dit aussi qu'ils se seraient inspirés de
chambord pour versailles
il voyait dans chambord peut-être le
premier symbole de la monarchie absolue
mais aussi de la souveraineté nationale
qui est le propriétaire aujourd'hui et
depuis quand on a vu ça tout à l'heure
ces questions pour un champion
alors je ne me rappelle plus des noms
mais je crois que c'est une famille un
peu de la noblesse en quelque sorte mais
je ne me rappelle plus non là je ne peux
pas répondre
ces genres de 100 villes qui va donner
la réponse c'est l'état depuis 1937
quasiment de 1915 au nom de la nation
donc c'est la nation le peuple français
la république française qui possède son
bord comment trouvez-vous le jard
barrière à la française jardins sont
magnifiques
je pense que les jardins ils ont été
renouvelés
[Musique]
qui a financé ses jardins ses du mécénat
américain stephen schwarzman qui a
apporté trois millions et demi d'euros à
chambord pour les parterres des jardins
à la française
il y a un grand médecin d'un groupe
français qui va être annoncé bientôt
mais qui est encore confidentiel pour
950 mille euros quand un peu de cuisine
[Musique]
question suivante c'est fini il ya plus
de questions les plus de questions je
tiens bon le cours s'est bien passé le
cours s'est bien passé à peu près
j'avais une bonne note
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]